the movie begins with a 17 year old
Maria Brennan preparing for school she
lives with her parents Dan and Amy in a
luxurious home but life appears to be
difficult for her because of her timid
nature Maria is an outcast at school and
she is often bullied by a guy named Mark
on the contrary her only friend Lily is
a confident figure skater and has a
boyfriend named Sean at times Maria
finds herself jealous of her friend
Maria's parents also worry about her
aloofness and they have tried to
convince her to go to the upcoming
School prom many times but without
success in contrast to most
stereotypical overprotective dads
Maria's father is only concerned about
her looks and social status he actually
thinks that she is screwed up because of
her disinterested boys or any social
activities Maria is aware about her
parents worries and one day she sneaks
into their room and tries to put on her
mother's makeup however she abruptly
stops when she notices something
protruding from the edge of the mirror
to her surprise it's a strange sonogram
image of twins in the middle of the
night Maria is in the bathroom when
suddenly her reflection in the mirror
stares back at her causing her to lose
her balance and fall she quickly gets up
and clears the steam from the mirror
gradually revealing her reflection to
Maria's utter shock the reflection
continues to move prompting her to run
away in horror the following day Maria
tries to tell her parents about the
incident but as expected they brush her
concerns aside later at school Maria is
once again bullied by Mark as he trips
her and makes her fall to the ground
everyone only laughs at her but
surprisingly Sean appears out of nowhere
and helps her up he even shoves Mark and
warns him to stay away from her this act
of kindness excites Maria as no one has
ever stood up for her before after
school she takes a relaxing bath
remembering her earlier encounter with
Sean but she isn't troubled by the sound
of a baby's cries the images of Maria's
own birth Flash in her mind and disturb
her peace afterwards she finds it
difficult to fall asleep suddenly a
voice calls out her name prompting her
to investigate lo and behold it is
revealed to be her own reflection in the
mirror Maria is initially scared but she
soon works up the courage to speak to
her the reflection calls herself aaram
and claims that she is Maria's complete
opposite confident charismatic and
dominant the two then chat for a while
and discuss their likes and dislikes as
they become friends Aram offers to
assist Maria in overcoming her problems
and becoming more confident the next day
Maria surprises her parents by
announcing that she wants to go to the
prom moreover later at school she
expresses interest in learning how to
skate for winter prom that evening Maria
goes to her father's Clinic to spend
some time with him as she watches him
get close to a female client she
suspects that he is having an affair on
the way back home Dan asks her to visit
him at the clinic tomorrow for an early
birthday present when Maria shares this
with her reflection that night she is
told that her father is a bad person who
only cares about himself Maria obviously
doesn't buy this so she defends her dad
saying that he is planning to gift her a
car however the next day Dan surprises
Maria with a cosmetic procedure instead
he tells her that he wants to fix her
unusually large ears and nose this
emotionally wrecks the teenager and she
finally realizes that Dan hates her
imperfections in the next scene arim
Comforts Maria and tells her that they
can their dad a lesson she also points
out that Amy is weak for putting up with
dense toxicity as the conversation drags
on Maria feels better and the two girls
share a laugh this attracts Amy's
attention and she asks Maria who she was
talking to when the latter isn't able to
give her a satisfactory answer Amy
begins to wonder if she's taking
narcotics later Amy shares her concerns
with Dan but he completely ignores the
matter instead he gives her some
sleeping pills applies a beauty cream to
her face and then puts her to bed before
dozing off Amy mentions that her
nightmares have returned but he assures
her that they will go away like they
always do the following day Maria and
Lily go to practice ice skating since
our protagonist girl has never stepped
foot on Ice before she easily slips and
falls to the ground however instead of
helping her up Lily rudely tells her to
stay away from Sean dejected that her
only friend has started disliking her
Maria returns home and confides an arum
the latter Comforts her for a while and
then explains how lily is a bad
influence the only thing she cares about
is her popularity Aram asserts she is
Maria's soul friend and the only one who
can alleviate her pain to achieve this
she proposes that Maria switched places
with her surrendering control of her
life the confused teenager almost gives
in and prepares to touch her reflection
but right then Amy arrives and tells her
that she's getting late for prom
startled Maria quickly puts on the prom
dress and rushes to school unfortunately
this turns out to be a bad decision as
she is overwhelmed by the bustling crowd
dazzling lights and booming music
fearing the possibility of falling Maria
finds it difficult to let go she
prepares to leave but Sean approaches
her at the last second and extends his
hand offering support Maria happily
accepts and so the two make their way to
the center of the rink and start dancing
in each other's arms Lily who is nearby
watches all of this go down and becomes
envious so she deliberately startles
Maria making her lose balance and fall
to the ground Sean tries to assist her
but Lily intervenes preventing him from
doing so to make matters worse the bully
Mark arrives at the scene and starts
pulling Maria across the rink all the
students simply watch her scream and
plead for help completely disregarding
how she is feeling when Mark finally
stopped Maria runs away from the
premises embarrassed this proves to be
the final straw for her so she
ultimately decides to let Aaron take
control over her life they touch hands
and lifts initiating the transformation
process like some sort of sexy Fusion
Dance once everything is done Maria is
the one behind the mirror while arum is
free to go anywhere she wants meanwhile
in the adjacent room Amy is having a
nightmare about the day she gave birth
to Maria in the dream she is screaming
in excruciating pain the next day Aaron
goes to school and encounters Mark in
the hallway she confidently walks up to
him grabs his crotch and licks his ear
before walking away leaving him
speechless all he wanted was a little
ASMR soon Lily approaches her and tries
to fake concern but Aram sees right
through her nevertheless she continues
to be friendly with Lily and asks her to
teach her how to skate again at the rank
later Abram goes to her father's Clinic
there she distracts the receptionist and
steals the number of Dan's mistress she
then arranges for the mistress and Amy
to come to the clinic at the same time
Aaron's plan works and Amy encounters
the mistress in the elevator she is
heartbroken when she realizes that her
husband is cheating on her the scene
then cuts to the ice rink where several
students have come to practice in the
meantime Aaron meets Mark and lures him
into the washroom once there she
suddenly strikes him in the knee with a
hockey stick causing it to dislocate
Mark collapses on the ground and screams
in agony he pleads for help but Abram
leaves him by himself to suffer soon
everyone heads home but Abram stays back
with Lily to practice skating she
surprisingly changes her demeanor and
starts skating like a pro much to her
friend's surprise then a sense of
determination takes over Aaron and she
begins chasing Lily with a deadly look
in her eyes scared Lily tries to get
away from her but ends up stumbling and
hitting her head on the hard cement she
profusely bleeds but arum only watches
her slowly succumb to her injuries after
a while Aaron calls the authorities and
informs them about Lily's accident while
pretending to be scared and worried for
her friend in the phone's reflection the
real Maria is seen crying later Aaron
returns home and a detective arrives to
interrogate her but Amy convinces him to
return at another time in the bathroom
confronts her about the murder but Aaron
menacingly says that Lily deserved it
hearing this Maria becomes scared and
expresses her desire to exchange
positions again but Aram refuses saying
that she is not done yet it literally
just hit me that Iram is Maria backwards
the scene then cuts to Lily's funeral
there the detective offers his
condolences to Sean and makes eye
contact with Aram this makes the latter
uncomfortable and she proceeds to leave
however Sean stops and Embraces her
later that night Abram sneaks out of her
house to visit Sean he takes her to his
room and offers her a joint as they
discuss their lives Aaron positions
herself in front of Sean and looks into
his eyes she then reveals that she has
been fantasizing about him and begins
touching him where the sun doesn't shine
Sean tries to stop her at first but soon
he eventually gives in and the two make
love the following day Aaron goes on a
dinner date with her father Dan is
worried about her well-being after
Lily's passing but Aram is entirely
unaffected by the incident it's also
revealed that after his affair had been
exposed Ben has been avoiding going home
Aaron questions him about his plans to
reconcile with Amy and he assures her
that he will soon make things go back to
normal arum then starts acting strange
eating loudly and unladylike this gets
into Dan's head and so he chastises her
to sit properly Aaron reluctantly
obliges but her resentment towards Dan
only continues to grow over the course
of the next few days Abram continues to
avoid School convincing Sean to Bunk
classes with her one day they check into
a motel to make love however sean gets a
call from his mommy informing him that
the police want to interrogate them
worried he plans to leave but Aram
refuses to go she then tries to tempt
Sean with kisses but this only makes him
suspicious and he asks why she's
avoiding the police realizing that she
has been exposed Abram grabs a bottle
and hits him on the head with it
unfortunately he passes away within a
few minutes after this Abram goes to the
bathroom and sees a hysterical Maria
crying her eyes out the two then get
close and comfort each other meanwhile
back at home Amy experiences another
nightmare in Her Dream we see that Maria
had a deformed twin sister and Dan
believed it was futile to let the baby
live so he made decision to euthanize
her it turns out Aram is actually
Maria's deceased twin sister ah it all
makes sense now back in reality arum
shows up at dance clinic and rings the
doorbell she stands weekly at the door
unable to support herself Dan carries
her to the operating table and fetches a
glass of water for her but to his
surprise she begins taking off her
clothes oh [__] enraged he demands that
she put her clothes back on but Aaron
begins to remove the rest of her garment
she then questions her father if he
finds her beautiful Dan reluctantly says
that she is beautiful but then she
inquires if he would still love her even
if she had deformities once again Dan
replies in the affirmative saying that
he would love her unconditionally
regardless of any imperfections however
Aaron doesn't believe him and swiftly
slashes his throat with a sharp object
after he bleeds to death an angry arum
questions why he couldn't love her in
the past afterwards she calls out for
Maria but doesn't get a response so she
returns home and lies next to a dazed
Amy the final scene concludes with
shimmering reflections and a depiction
of Amy embracing both her daughters in
her arms this indicates that Aram and
Maria have turned into a single person
yeah yeah okay I just double checked
with my reflection we both think that
that movie was ridiculous subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching